el comité nobel noruego ha decidido
premiar con el premio nobel de paz 2020
al programa mundial de alimentos por sus
esfuerzos por combatir el hambre por su
contribución a mejorar las condiciones
de paz en zonas afectadas por conflictos
actuar como fuerza impulsora en
esfuerzos para prevenir el uso del
hambre como arma de guerra y conflictos
el programa mundial de alimentos hace
parte de naciones unidas y es la
organización humanitaria más grande a
nivel global asiste a cerca de 100
millones de personas en 88 países del
mundo anualmente el comité destacó que
la erradicación del hambre es uno de los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible al
tiempo que alertó que en 2019 135
millones de personas sufrían de hambre
aguda por lo que pidió que los ojos del
mundo se enfoquen en resolver esta
problemática actualmente la plataforma
cuenta con unos 17.000 trabajadores y
los responsables de la iniciativa les
dedicaron el galardón
estamos muy contentos esperemos que esto
sea un nuevo impulso para los
trabajadores humanitarios tan dedicados
que trabajan en algunas de las zonas de
más difícil acceso y en circunstancias
muy complejas a menudo viven viajan
dejan a sus familias para estar al
servicio de la humanidad el secretario
general de naciones unidas antonio
guterres celebró el premio el programa
mundial de alimentos opera por encima de
la política las necesidades humanitarias
impulsan
la organización sobrevive gracias a las
contribuciones voluntarias de los
estados miembros de la onu y del público
en general esa solidaridad es necesaria
ahora para enfrentar no solo la pandemia
sino todas las pruebas mundiales de
nuestro tiempo el programa mundial de
alimentos ha resaltado que 2020 ha sido
un año crítico a nivel global a causa
del cobi 19 se estima que en total 690
millones de personas sufren de hambre en
el mundo